let's play hockey we've had to wait months to say
it exciting time and we are underway in downtown
St Paul the Wild win the draw and the puck comes
down into Florida territory wild fans saw a lot
of molo when he was in St Louis was traded to
the Rangers last year at the trade deadline
part of the teraso trade kulakov out to center
right gagoski has it there for the wild well how
about that play from gagoski he he picks a puck
up off his backhand on the wall takes it right to
the middle gets a shot with generat a rebound and
you know again Jared sper being out that's a right
shot you got two lefties on that pair it's hard
to hold those Pucks in gagoski veteran nice move
there marov in for Florida stood up by gagoski
Middleton there to pick it up around the wall but
right on the stick of Rodriguez Rodriguez tried
to Center Veri was there out front barov a shot
Miss sa by gustofson Baldi re lays to Center Eric
s hustling after it mahura got there first Baldi
grabs a loose Puck at Center Baldi backpedals
down the wall back to the line Faber a shot he
scores Brock Faber with The Season's first goal
and Minnesota [Music] [Applause] [Music] leads
great play by Matt baly to just hold this up and
it buys favor some time draws the Florida Winger
down a little B bit lot of room for Brock
Faber to get this one through and he does we
talked to him this offseason about what he was
working on he said I really want to shoot the
Pu a little bit had to go off the St and right
to capriso he couldn't find the handle quickly
enough to get a shot away kulakov to Center ice
it looked like it was going to be a dangerous
play gson makes a pad stop and then covers turns
after that bouncing puck in the offensive zone
to get behind and Middleton here he lik to
just stick with the player ends up finding
bragi on front but that's a second third
time beat Toronto and Carolina on their
way to the final went 7 and0 in overtime
games during that postseason [Applause]
run wild start with ericon Johansson up
front Rodin and Faber on defense for the
closing seconds of this power play Parov to the
Minnesota line and it knocked away Johansson's
there for Minnesota it harman's back on wild
at full strength and Fa comes away with it one
touch at Center Johansson feeds broin broin moves
into chuck had had over a hundred the year before
in Calgary that big deal that sent kachuck to
Florida and Jonathan hubero the other way this
one goes off the post for slashing rather here's
the crossbar from sasevich out it to Middleton
back for gagoski [Applause] zuk carello back to
gagoski moves in off the post just before this
gagoski yeah he didn't get a lot on this just a
well placed shot to that Far Side tell how low B
br's glove it wild will go with four forwards
off this draw ericon X able to win the draw
zcell back to capriso zukar tried to go cross
top front ericon x scor a power play goal for
Minnesota it takes him just 7 Seconds four on
three and it's 20-0 Minnesota but zukar really
kind of tries to force one to that backside Joe
Hanson they catch a break cuz Florida gets a
piece of it slows it down and enough Eric Sak is
just sitting out front all alone you know that's
just a good stick from the Florida Defender
but it's a great balance for the wild heading
to act to where he can handle it he makes a
patient play bringing it to the forehand but
and he's ready you know it isn't one of those and
I don't necessarily love this move where you've
got a franchise player and you just throw the
letter on their chest early on and say it's your
team buddy let's let's all grow up together like
can't of Ed earn his stripes and you know Rossy
scor young gu showing up for the wild here
tonight this line kind of got things started
in the second period of the good four check
here they get there again this time it's
Freddy gdo who gets the loose Puck throws it
out front to a streaking Marco Rossi it's the
work without the puck from Rossi he gets his
feet going at the blue line that creates the
separation cadro sees him beautiful pass out
front nice collection and then bossk's down
how much easier that might make life for Marco
rosi so evident there they both made good plays
on the boards yeah they're working without
the puck to get in there they get inside
position all three wild forwards do and that's
working as a group again you like to see that
and that's where success comes from it's all
three doing the same thing putting the work
in and it takes a couple of passes a couple
of battles and then eventually leads to the
goal after reviewing the play could you please
reset the clock to 505 the play was offside we
have no [Applause] goal yeah through the
feet you can see off sides skate is up no
body part across the blue and forsling has it
for Florida wild have certainly leveled the ice
here in the last half of the second period
they have and it's pingol Lindell moves in
Saved by gusterson and a sprawling play by
Hartman to break it up on the back door and
Reinhard finds lell on the back side he chips
the first one that gets through then s scavage
tries to bring it to the back and terrific
recovery from guson to seal that post to make
sure svich can't get anything on this rebound
opportunity watch the push the slide [Applause]
seal du shorthanded right off the draw wax one
right into the midsection of bosski last year
they were second in the NHL with 12 short-handed
goals second only two aded and when you can you
create a three onone a back score play scored
handed then win a face off to where porland FS the
loose Puck for Florida centering pass right out
front Sam kevich Deni by Guston solos poring on
the rebound Sam svich again sent it over the top
of the net kachuck tries to Center clear to the
corner final seconds of the period wild hanging
on gagoski got a stick on it last year in Block
shots out of the lineup other guys stepping up
to get the job done Rodriguez holds the Zone
Amman Larson with it to barov who moves in kachuck
tries to tuck it in save by Guston now kachuck on
the short side tries to wrap this one looking for
any kind of daylight five hole gets it under the
pad but not enough juice on it Rodriguez will
find ran Haron the wild have been able to turn
both aside pther back in Rodriguez side of the net
Reinhardt tried to tuck it in on the back end gson
got the glove back on it this one barov redirect
or Reinhardt sorry short side then he tries to go
for him back and get it past the goal line throw
it in there bagy looking for a lane can't find it
barov emman Larson his shot tipped out front
by kachuck bagy a shot and that was blocked
eventually they throw one that way and they get
it two onone on front Chuck's kind of alone he's
got a B G's got a battle two shots off battling
for it for Minnesota he looks exhausted as he
tries to win a battle against fory Baldi couldn't
get it by Ean Larson a shot saved by gson ericon
has barov tied up B go down in the corner barov
back on his feet with a puck kachuck throws it
out front Json slides across got a shoulder on
one more good just there he just on it kachuck
to barov centered bounces free to kachuck Tipp
by gdo and out to Center Panthers have to tag
up down to 10 seconds left 41 saves from guson
tonight the wild have had more saves than a shut
out only twice in franchise history the GBS stops
all 41 and the Wild winning that opening night